GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR. MONDAY MARCH
NINETEENTH IS HEREBY COLD ORDER.
A PIECE REVISED AND AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING OF THE SPURS.
IT'S ALSO BEING TELEVISED.
A MATTER SECTOR PRESCHOOL.
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM ALLEN
BROKE CARE FOR RIO CERVANTES
HERE.
FRIEDMAN GRAYSON.
AS AREA SOLACE WALDRON. NEVER.
OF VERY GOOD WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE DO OF CONSENT AGENDA BUT
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE ARE GOING TO
REMOVE MR. CUNNINGHAM'S AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY SIX FROM THE
REFERRAL LIST.
FOR PURPOSES OF TODAY'S.
IS OUR MOST ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA.
MOVE OVER SOUTH SECOND WHEN SHE
BROKE THINK FOR ALL. A MATTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM ALLEN BROUGH. BROUGH
AYE CARILLO CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE NAZARIAN AYE
NAZARIAN AYE SOLACE AYE SOLOS
AYE WALDRON.
THE MOTION PASSED AND OF THIS
RULES COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED
THINKING FOR. ALL.
THAT'S WHEN I. DISCOVERED BY.
THIS MEANING THIS JUROR.